نحن الان نقف على مفترق دوله هذا المفترق
الوحيد المطل الى المفترق الكويتي وهو
الممر الوحيد لالتقاط لقمه العيش المغمس
بالبارود والدم حشود المواطنين المتجهه في
هذا المشهد لالتقاط كيس الدقيق او حتى بعض
المساعدات التي تدخل الى شمال قطاع غزه
بعد المجاعه التي حلت في هذه المنطقه
وخاصه بالتحديد شمال وادي قطاع غزه الان
كل هذه الجماهير والحشود متجهه الى منطقه
الدوار الكويتي سنقتل اكثر ونسمع اراء
الناس واصواتهم بعد ان حلت الكارثه في
شمال قطع غزه الكل خايف بس الواحد يعني
بيته ما فيش عنده اكل ولا شرب بده يجيب
كيس لطحين طعم الصغار وطعم اهل البيت تبعه
نضلنا قاعدين زي ما احنا لا اي شعورك
يجيلك ابنك بدي خبزه يا بابا ايش شعورك
مين هذا مين ب يتحمل الولد الصغير اللي
يجيب له خبز ما فيش حدا الابو هو اللي بده
يروح يجيب انا عندي مع المره والولد خمس
تنفع انت عارف انه هدول كلهم استشهاديين
قول لي كيف استشهاديين هذا بيطلع الواحد
بع بودع مراته وودع وبروح بجيب يا بنشد يا
بنروح في علبتين ثلاثه طيب والله العظيم
لنا 25 يوم ما اخذنا شيء ماتت المراه
والاولاد بعوض الله بس اليوم ننا بندور
على كيس طحين مطعم غيرهم بندور مش اكثر
اليوم بقول لك كيس طحين ب 6 مليون من وين
بتروح تشتريه ب 6 مليون 7 مليون طيب و 7
مليون من وين تشتريه كل يوم بتروح انت كل
يوم بتحد بوصل الدبابه عشان اجيب كيس طحين
مش خايف على نفسي انا خايف على كيس الطحين
مش اكثر عشان اطعم الاولاد هيني جيت من
معسكر جبالي انا ساكن في معسكر جباليا انا
شارد يعني نازح من بيت حنون على معسكر
جباليا وهيني جيت من معسكر جباليا على
دوار الكويت مشي عشان اجيب طحين لاولادي
عند اليهود الله اعلم نموت ولا نطيب المهم
بدنا نجيب اكل لقمه العيش يعني زي ما
بقولوا صعبه مش خايف تموت يا حج ايش بدي
الحق اودي امش مع السلامه بدي الحقهم بدي
الحقهم راح اودي هنا خمس شهداء تحت الردم
لليوم لليوم الاف المواطنين المتجهين الى
منطقه الدوار الكويتي بعد ان بات شمال
قطاع غزه
بمجاهد من القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصل
الاثنان يلتقيان في سياسه الاحتلال في منع
دخول المساعدات الى شمال قطاع غزه الان كل
هذه الحشود تتجه لالتقاط فقط كيس اما من
الطحين او اما باقه مساعدات او صندوق
مساعدات هذا ان دخلت الى شمال قطاع
غزه الغول الجزيره مدينه غزه